ce matin dans la matinale de rtl france
pour parler de cette journée
internationale de solidarité avec le
peuple palestinien et on le disait dans
un climat de sentiment de trahison avec
notamment la normalisation des relations
entre israël et des pays acp à rabat à
laquelle on assiste c'est derrière moi
quel impact ces normalisation est long
sur la question il serait il là sur la
question palestinienne aujourd'hui
c'est un coup dur on va pas dire inverse
mais c'est un coup dur dont il ne faut
pas non plus exagérer la portée pour ce
qui d'abord l'ampleur reste assez
modeste
quelques états de la péninsule arabique
qui sont des pétromonarchies avec une
diplomatie occidentale et étasuniennes
parfaitement établie donc rien de neuf
si ce n'est qu'on officialise et puis il
ya le maroc voilà le maroc c'est un peu
gros morceau mais finalement on
officialise ce qui existait on il y
avait des ghz écran de fumée et là on
rentre dans la réalité pour donner
simplement un élément historique il faut
rappeler que la guerre de 1967 a été une
grande victoire israélienne parce que le
maroc était un fort parce que les
dirigeants et qui serait bien été
informé en sous main par hassan ii tous
assez documenté ses racines de
participer aux réunions de la ligue
arabe et donner les informations à
israël pour leur dire là vous pouvez
attaquer c'est le bon moment donc et on
voit par ailleurs que vis-à-vis des
peuples ça ne passe pas donc pour
corriger un peu compenser l approche
négative je dirais qu une approche
positive c'est à dire que tous ces gens
font ce qu'ils font font des plans font
des guerres font mais il ya une chose
qu'ils ont pas pu résoudre ce qui est un
peuple palestinien et le peuple
palestinien il est là les familles elles
sont renversés par des opinions diverses
d'un autre frère et soeur entre parents
et enfants ça discute énormément en
palestine mais un palestinien il c'est
qu'ils les palestiniens et leur grande
force c'est que les palestiniens de gaza
les païens de cisjordanie des
palestiniens de jérusalem les
palestiniens
de 1948 les palestiniens des camps les
palestiniens exilés à travers seulement
sont un seul peuple qui est toujours
prêt à se réunir et ça personne ne
pourra rien y faire donc le principe du
droit à l'autodétermination
il reste intacte personnes oui et
concernant justement la politique du
nouveau gouvernement israélien de
naftali bennet bennett on en est où avec
eux dans les relations avec les
palestiniens
on évite quelques provocations qui était
la grande joie de netanyahu mais pour le
reste est absolument rien de neuf c'est
à dire qu'on construit une histoire où
il ya un ennemi absolu c'est le peuple
palestinien et le peuple israélien ne
peut vivre que s'ils éliminent si les
cartes sim riddim s'ils brisent le
peuple palestinien c'est exactement la
même philosophie quand c était le
ministre des affaires il était le
responsable militaire sous netanyahu eut
donc et bennett est pareil tu as été un
homme qui serait qualifié d'extrême
droite tantôt dans nos énergies mais
encore avec des options très marqué
donc il n'y a pas de changement non ça
c'est on peut pas dire qu'il y ait de
changement et il ya quelques
provocations en moins mais il reste
toujours dans une option qui est une
heure non entièrement fausses qui est
d'enfermer les palestiens dans une
négociation avec israël donc ils disent
le mandat finalement nous avait donné
tout en 1967 on sait pas très bien quel
était le statut donc machine qui a vendu
récupérer sa donc commandé démocratique
on connaît des gens très bien on peut
restituer des droits aux palestiniens
mais les palestiniens doivent discuter
avec nous c'est comme cela qu'on a écrit
l'autorité palestinienne sauf qu'on voit
que ça c'est une impasse et éthiques
notez international aujourd'hui
alors je n'ai pas entendu la question
grâce une politique de colonisation qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas condamnée par la
communauté internationale
simon oui c'est ça avec elle est
condamnée par démont mais quant aux roms
jeu byden en disant voilà on conteste
les colonies bon ça va c'est bien gentil
moi on va nous parler de choses
concrètes il ya un arrêt senghor qui a
été rendu par la cour de justice de
l'union européenne en 2019 ça concerne
par les états unis ça concerne toute
l'europe l'europe ses 27 états la cour
de justice a validé une décision de la
commission européenne en dix ans les
produits importés qui viennent des
colonies donne à voir une mention est il
une étiquette colonies israéliennes en
palestine voilà on doit informer le
consommateur pour qu'ils sachent ce
qu'ils achètent alors commençons déjà
par faire selon vous comprenez c'est ça
ce sont des choses concrètes ensuite
qu'il n'est pas la maîtrise sur les
latitudes qui est de délivrer des permis
de construire ça ce sera un autre débat
mais je dis aussi et parce que nous
travaillons beaucoup avec les
palestiniens ça je peux vraiment vous
garantir c'est à dire qu'il n'ya aucun
défaitisme suit les pas des signes moi
je travaille comme avocat avec les
palestiniens en cisjordanie à jérusalem
à gaza au liban nous avons des contacts
de partout ils sont dans une bonne dans
une lutte ils savent qu'aucun effort ne
sera épargné
et ils ont un grand espoir actuellement
ces espaces devant la cour pénale
internationale qui évidemment l'israël
élimine deux centres de son ressort or
qu'est-ce qui a dit la cour pénale en
février 2010 21 ses terres ses vacances
victoire de cette année la cour a dit la
palestine est un état et avec
souveraineté sur la cisjordanie
jérusalem est et gaza donc jérusalem qui
est soi-disant annexée et déjà contestés
et donc c'est la grande entrée des
palestiniens dans le droit international
on sort de cette relation toxique qui
est quelqu un qu une impasse en disant
il faut négocier qu'israël parce qu'il
serait un atout ya que lui qui peut vous
restituer des droits et bien non on
s'est battu pendant dix ans contre cette
théorie en disant ce sont des droits
propres pas si un droit à
l'autodétermination ce peuple est uni il
a une histoire il a le droit à
l'autodétermination il est souvent sur
ses terres la cour nous a donné raison
et maintenant l'enquêté en cours alors
qu'est ce qu'on constate évidemment
c'est moins lisible que d'autres
événements plus plus plus visuel je
dirais c'est que israël a dit mais la
cour pénale elle est antisémite et nous
refuse de vivre sur notre terre donc on
comparera pas en ligne or donc
premièrement israël refuse le droit
international miss met à l'écart des
communautés et deuxièmement tout ce qui
est pas destiné c'est à dire le fatah
cedh mais évidemment mais
également le hamas le jihad islamique le
fplp ont reconnu la cour pénale
internationale la nécessité de coopérer
et leur accord pour coopérer avec la
justice internationale pour rétablir le
droit donc qui assied terroristes qui
sait ce qui viole le droit à ce jour ben
moi je constate que la palestine dit je
me soumets au droit international et je
mets tous les efforts pour coopérer avec
le procureur et que de l'autre côté andy
on ignore ce procureur qui ignore lui
même le droit international donc il ya
un jeu de puissance il ya un jeu d'armes
est un jeu d'argent mais
fondamentalement en 2021 ce sont les
palestiniens qui l'emportent parce que
l'arm véritable celle de droit
international alors on décembre 2014 en
france l'assemblée nationale a reconnu
l'état de palestine dans les frontières
de 1967 avec jérusalem-est jérusalem est
comme capitale sept ans plus tard niçois
hollande nice où emmanuel macron ce vote
n'a été concrétisé comment est-ce qu'on
peut le comprendre comment vous
l'expliquez
c'est le dim le double discours
l'ambiguïté et
l'impossibilité pour la diplomatie
française dédiée à clairement les choses
à ses interlocuteurs vous évoquez le
sahara occidental et le le le la sortie
sans reconnaissance peu par les états
unis de souveraineté bon la france elle
est partie en procès qui est en cours la
française sait très bien ce qu'il en est
elle est incapable de dire au maroc tu
seras pas s'ouvrait sur ce territoire
parce que ça a été jugé qu'un soir pour
l'avant donc vis-à-vis de la palestine
évidemment qui a un état et d'ailleurs
quand elle est là la palestine et les
etam en est un non membre de l'onu mais
les qualifier comme état elle a ratifié
de très nombreux tt elle a ratifié les
conventions de genève et la france comme
tous les pays européens sont notamment
partis à la cour pénale internationale
ou la pas dessiner comme état donc quand
vous êtes à paris on vous dira non je
sais qu'on va faire quelque chose mais
quand même vous reconnaitre commettra
c'est trop compliqué et puis quand on va
à la haye où siège à côté de l'état de
palestine qui est un état comme les
autres donc
je crois que des émissions comme les
votes sont extrêmement intéressante dans
la mesure où on a le temps de creuser et
de dire ce genre de chose vu que je dis
que la france ne reconnaît pas l'état de
palestine à paris mais qu'elle le
reconnaît à la haye voilà quand il eu
discussion sur l'état de palestine le
procureur a ouvert un grand débat
international en disant messi en a qui
sont opposés alors de tous les pays
européens et que l'allemagne et
l'autriche qui ont dit nous on a des
réserves voilà l'allemagne à un penseur
on a beaucoup regardé le mémoire de
l'allemagne c est aimer vraiment depuis
toute petite chose en disant oui parce
que des dispositions techniques mais
l'allemagne elle dit les colonies non
c'est impossible il faut respecter la
frontière de 1967 et donc hélas l'est de
la france elle n'a pas dit un mot devant
la cour pénale c'est à dire que doit le
camp pénal elle a accepté que c'était
bien en état donc je vous dire qu'il ya
beaucoup d' enthousiasme dans l'énoncé
les dents dans le peuple palestinien qui
suit cette affaire le lait de la
décision des sacrés brighella vraiment
été saluée comme une victoire évidemment
c'est des procédures qui prennent du
temps mais pour moment l'histoire est en
train de s'écrire dans un sens qui est
donné tort aux puissances occidentales
et de donner raison au peuple
palestinien
voilà qui s'organisent par lui-même
après il se trouve dans une situation de
dépendance économique et il y a
tellement difficulté divinité pour la
santé est l'impossibilité de se déplacer
entre les territoires que c'est très
très difficile pour eux mais là l'un là
au risque de surprendre je dirais qu'à
ce jour la main gagnante elle et prenez
pas des siens parce qu'ils ont droit
avec eux merci sont l'une ils ont lu et
eddy peuple beaucoup plus qu'on le pense
quand il a fallu faire les élections qui
ont donc ont été suspendues cette année
elles ont été suspendues par hommes sur
bath uniquement parce que les laits la
partie annexée de jérusalem ne ne
pouvaient pas voter bon c'est un
argument qui vaut ce qu'il vaut je me
prononce pas là-dessus mais je constate
qu'il y avait 99 % des palestiniens qui
étaient sur les i drive ont confirmé
leur inscription et que tous les groupes
politiques participer à ces élections et
quel est le pays arabe et notamment ceux
qui ont sauté en ratifier des accords
d'avram qui peut se féliciter d'une
telle vie démocratique donc les
palestiniens ils sont très forts a
raison pas fini de nous merci beaucoup
pour votre éclairage ce matin dans la
matinale de france merci gilles devers
avocat au barreau de lyon et spécialiste
du droit international